make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob I think
I'm gonna go to the Ultra Music Festival
actually I probably do you like Miami
Music Week in March of 2019 and then I'm
buying tickets for the Olympics in 2020
and Tokyo Japan
I am excited for that we do in this baby
anyway we are covering heroes in crisis
DC's heroes in crisis event so this is
it's really like a highly anticipated
event here's one of the things to bear
in mind guys those guys who were new to
DC Comics whenever a story with the word
crisis gets thrown out of their people
initiative like basically you'd think
that it's gonna be like a cosmic event
because historically speaking that's
always been the case like when it comes
to these major cosmic events I really
started with crisis on Infinite Earths
zero-hour crisis and time then it became
Infinite Crisis then Final Crisis but
you also had identity crisis in there
which is the first time that you had an
event like that that wasn't cosmic in
scope which means to say it didn't
impact the entire universe like it
wasn't being destroyed or something
along those lines and this is another
one this heroes in crisis doesn't deal
with like the the end of the world it
actually deals with like how superheroes
function and what they do when they're
basically suffering from PTSD and this
is cool because what this does is it
initially picks up with Booster Gold and
there's really no better care to depict
then like somebody like him that's
dealing with you know essentially like
crisis level events because we know from
the most recent story for example in
Detective Comics that Booster Gold had
the idea to like save Batman basically
like give him like the gift that Booster
wanted to give Batman was like the
perfect life and so we went back in time
and saved his parish from being killed
and that caused all kinds of problems
because then it turned out that like you
know his parents ended up being killed
anyway and so it's kind of crazy when it
comes to Bruce Wayne's whole idea and
Booster Gold trying to do the right
thing and and so on and so forth and so
what this does is it initially switches
over to Harley Quinn now these are a
series of interviews that DC kind of
throws in there for the purpose of
establishing what sanctuary is now we
know by definition from the various
stories that we've seen that sanctuary
is where the heroes go when they're
dealing with a crisis of sorts when the
the overwhelming aspect of being a hero
becomes too much for them to bear
sanctuary is where they're supposed to
go to but it's largely been ambiguous up
to this point we didn't really know what
sanctuary was about we didn't know if it
was spearheaded by some doctor somewhere
we don't really we didn't really know if
it was just an organization where
superheros just sit down and talk to
other superheroes and that's it there is
no exterior source out there there's no
doctors or you know no medicine or
anything like that we didn't really know
how that worked and so Harley Quinn's
interview here I guess heard talking
point really just kind of comes with the
nature of her character in saying that
like she
familiar with trauma because she used to
be like a psychologist or somebody that
worked with individuals minds but as she
began to go crazy by virtue of the Joker
she's kind of sorted to switch to this
idea of somebody saying like like crate
like these people out there with all
these problems like we should just like
smash them with a sledge hammer we
should just like get rid of them which
is kind of an extreme and extreme point
but she also kind of has a breakdown
towards the end and that's the cool
thing about this because you see this
sort of systematic adjustment to her
character the first she starts off
confident then she starts to use comedy
as like as a defense mechanism and then
she starts to get to like the inner part
of herself and then she starts to cry
and so it's really one of these like one
of these moments where she sort of it's
like you're her character being broken
down as one of these things were like
all she needed to do was just talk and
so what this does is it jumps back over
to Booster Gold and it's kind of funny
because in this initial segment there
was this you know this diner woman who
was like hey there's another hero here
and boo she's like that's not a hero
that's a villain it's like well is it
gonna be a fight and he's like yes it's
gonna be a fight and it's kind of a cool
thing because the way this unfolds that
the way that that like Tom King does
this is so cool it's like a fight that's
building to anticipation because you're
talking about like Harley Quinn showing
up here on the scene and then it's just
kind of like it's only a matter of time
before they fight nobody else really
seems to know and even booster booster
gold's aware this is gonna turn into a
fight Harley Quinn's like yeah this is
gonna turn into a fight and so it's
really just kind of like when do we
strike it's one of those classic sort of
like like you know Mexican standoff
scenes you know for example from like
you know the good the bad the ugly at
the end the Mexican standoff scene that
lasted like 10 minutes before anybody
started shooting anybody else it was
kind of weird but at this point we
switch over to Superman and we kind of
get Superman just sort of arriving on
the scene for a particular location now
again the invocation of Superman in this
story means that it that we're not
dealing with like small beans here that
we're dealing with a pretty significant
event and so from here we jump over to a
guy named blue jay
now blue jay was a character who was
originally introduced back in 1971 in
Justice League of America issue number
87 I'm pretty sure and he was created by
Michael Friedrich now with regards to to
his character he's kind of like ant-man
in a sense that like he can shrink down
the difference is that he grows wings
when he shrinks but the funny thing
about this is that he really just kind
of says like like I can control my power
under normal circumstances I'm very good
at it
but as time has progressed I seem to
have lost control of my power and so
it's one of these things where it sort
of feels like he has like a mental block
in place now blue jay is a pretty
small-time guy I mean he's he's not a
big superhero which is probably why
you've never
these small fish but the cool thing
about this is this kind of you know tom
kean telling us that the struggle of
being a superhero isn't relegated to
just the big guys right it's not like
you know the struggle of being Superman
and struggling being Batman or Wonder
Woman or Aquaman or something like that
it affects everybody in some former
fashion big and small which is actually
a pretty cool idea
it's very akin to like Civil War from
Marvel Comics those you guys who read
that well you basically had like like
everybody from the top at big guys
Captain America Iron Man so on all the
way down to the bottom with like Heroes
for Hire
who were basically experiencing this
rift in the superhero community so it's
kind of a cool concept but from here of
course the fight breaks out between
Harley Quinn and Booster Gold and it
goes exactly as you would expect it to I
mean for the most part Buescher is able
to hold his own but Harley Quinn's
driven by absolute insanity and madness
and so when she starts lashing out it's
just kind of like look she's not gonna
stop here I mean she's just sort of lost
her mind in the moment and so what we
end up doing is switching over to a to
Batman to Superman and to Wonder Woman
now this is basically the Trinity that
we're dealing with here and that really
seems to be what this story's boiling
down to in a lot of ways can we also
just say here this is an amazing drawing
clay man's the one who's drawing who's
doing like the art for the comic and it
looks amazing like I would want this
framed without the speech bubbles like
just the just the picture and no speech
bubbles dude I would love that like that
would be that like have that and frame
at my house it would be on there's
anyway with the Trinity of DC Comics
it's one of the important things when
you're talking about what's basically a
whodunit murder mystery the Trinity is
oftentimes invoke didn't invoked more
than anybody else and the reason we call
them the Trinity is because they're kind
of like the the if there was such a
thing the one-two-three punch of DC
Comics really the comic book industry
Batman of course is the original
antihero Superman's the original
superhero and Wonder Woman is the
original light you know female empowered
superhero and so you take all three of
these things and it's like these are the
three that the top three heroes that DC
has but them arriving if sanctuary is
predicated on the idea that someone's
been going around and killing
superheroes but you basically end up
having like this this field full of
bodies you've got you've got like you
know some of whom are our small-time
guys some of whom are pretty big guys
but they've all basically been killed
off and so what we end up doing is
having Superman enter into this house
only for us to find the two biggest
players in the DC Universe so far who
have been killed off Arsenal red arrow
and while in the red haired Wally West
and this is actually pretty big because
the question is who the hell killed them
like it's you know doing this is
is it's it's kind of crazy the way Tom
King does this because of you could take
it a couple different ways the fact that
is just kind of like wall-e and Arsenal
are confirmed dead wide you would think
it would be like a big dramatic moment
when like you end up finding out they're
dead but it's just kind of like yep
they're dead alongside everybody else is
kind of the feeling that you get but
what this also seems to point out is
that this is indicative of a much bigger
picture there's something far more
significant going on here the death of
these characters alongside all these
other you know essentially small-time
superheroes is really designed to say
that their deaths are a byproduct of
somebody out there being vengeful or
what-have-you but they're all
superheroes that at the end of the day
Wally West's arsenal don't are are
really no different from all the other
heroes who were out there regardless of
how small they are they all fight crime
they all try to be the bad guys and they
all struggle with being a superhero in
their own length that they all have
their own their own desires their own
motivations all the things that they
regret and they suffer from and so
that's kind of the crazy scenario is
because what we're basically told here
is that sanctuary was set up by like
Batman Superman and Wonder Woman as a
place for superheroes to deal with like
the process of struggling to deal with
what it means to be a hero to deal with
like the emotional toll that it takes
which is pretty cool because that's
something you never really see in DC
comics and it really in coming books as
a whole and in reality that's just a
holdover from the Silver Age this is the
holdover from like 1950s comic books
there back then back in the day you had
superheroes who fought the bad guys and
the superheroes beat the bad guys and
then the day was done and that was it
and you might see some emotional
struggle in their comics with regards to
like the loss of something for example
1971 Peter Parker loses Gwen Stacy 1972
I think it was eobard thawne killed iris
West
and so yah Barry Allen went you know
went out and killed eobard thawne I mean
you have like these moments where it
kind of impacts the characters but no
one's had really dealt with the idea of
like when the hero saves the day who
saves the hero that's that's the
question that that none of the comic
book companies ever really dealt with
before and so it's really really cool to
see this happen and so it's almost kind
of crushing because it almost seems as
though the entire basis behind sanctuary
is sort of all for naught that these
people were all brought here to find a
place of Solace to find a place of
comfort to find a place of healing and
instead they found death and so is it's
it's pretty sad to see and so switching
over to to Harley and Booster Gold you
know it's one of these things where they
sort of have this conversation back and
forth and Booster Gold starts making
allusions to the idea and then actually
makes kind of an outright statement that
Harley Quinn was the one who killed
everyone and that's what's so crushing
is is this like you went there and you
killed
every single person and Harley Quinn
says no no I didn't kill anybody I'm not
the one who's responsible for everyone
dying here the person who's responsible
for that booster is you and so basically
we get this kind of transition to
Booster Gold himself where he's doing
his interview and he's saying like I
know exactly what you guys are about
which makes sense because he's from the
future but he's like I know exactly what
you guys are about I know exactly what
you guys do you guys are an organization
that essentially like the the overseers
the ones that help the superheroes get
through their crises or essentially
robots built on Kryptonian tech that are
a combination of Superman Batman and
Wonder Woman's personalities and so
Booster Gold simply says yeah like I'm
here to start talking like I'm here for
help and so it leaves things very very
ambiguous because we don't really know
what what involvement Booster Gold had
here we don't really know if he outright
killed everyone if he set in motion a
set of events that led to all their
deaths if it's some villain that Booster
Gold set off by virtue of being there
and talking to them or something like
that we don't really know and that's one
of the cool things here is there so many
possibilities it's entirely possible
that this organization sanctuary will
eventually go awry that will basically
see what amounts to like a small time
futures in or you end up having like
these Kryptonian robots to take over the
bodies of the superheroes and try to
destroy the world there's any number of
things that that could play out in this
scenario so it's pretty interesting and
it's actually pretty cool and it works
pretty well because of course it creates
a lot of anticipation for the next issue
okay so we're covering part two of DC's
heroes in crisis and as I read through
this I started thinking about something
and I have a theory and I'll run over
that theory at the end of the video I
have an idea on who it is that's behind
it but anyway so as we know with heroes
in crisis so far Wally West and an
Arsenal are like the two big heroes to
die I mean we know that like like the
heroes in crisis event centers on the
creation of something called sanctuary
but sanctuary was a place where heroes
and even sometimes villains could go to
like get the burden off their shoulders
it was a place for those who have powers
where they could go and basically not
keep all their emotions and thoughts
bottled up and push them towards like a
breaking point because that's one thing
to bear in mind a lot of the heroes who
are out there are masked heroes they
have dual identities they they really
can't just like walk into a
psychologists office and say hey Doc I
got problems I'm Batman and I really
struggle letting people know that
because I'm walking in this balance line
at being like Batman and Bruce Wayne by
the way please don't tell anybody
because all it would take is just like a
judge with a court order to make that
information come out I mean they have to
give it up and so because of this they
need a place where heroes could go and
talk they could - essentially a quote
unquote can
best their sins take that burden off
their shoulders and go back to being
heroes again the whole basis behind this
was that someone somewhere went into
sanctuary and just killed a whole bunch
of heroes most of whom he hadn't even
heard of but a couple of big names were
in there you know again the death of
Wally the death of red arrow of Arsenal
that was pretty big stuff and so this
picking up with poison ivy is intriguing
here because poison ivy isn't so much a
tried-and-true villain anymore as she is
like kind of an antihero almost that
she's almost kind of reforming herself
you know kind of going back to being a
hero
so does burly's becoming a hero so to
speak and it's kind of a cool thing
because you end up having Harley Quinn
who jumps in the middle of all this now
this is very easy to write off but it's
actually very very important because
what this tells us is Harley Quinn was
not supposed to be there that she was at
sanctuary we know that from the very
first issue she was at sanctuary but she
wasn't supposed to be there that because
of the fact that she is in love to her
and in poison ivy or a thing together
that she essentially just kind of snuck
along not only that we're not even
really told how people are supposed to
be there that Poison Ivy's there but
we're not really told if you have to be
invited or anything along those lines
now we'll also get another another part
of this puzzle in Harley Quinn will kind
of reveal how it was a poison ivy got
there but what is it happening as Harley
Quinn is essentially like the way this
is written there are two things going on
one Booster Gold did it - it looks like
Holley Quinn did an enteric Booster Gold
into believing that he did it that's
kind of how this seems to unfold here
and Harley Quinn showing up at the lair
of the penguin is basically like hey
look I need a place to lie low for a
while this is the other cool thing - is
what I love about clay man a lot of
times in in comic books for those you
guys who renew here a lot of times in
comic books you'll see different
villains draw in different ways and
sometimes you'll see them drawn in a way
where it's like that looks kind of
ridiculous right like you think of
Oswald Cobblepot and you think of like
the penguin from like Batman the
Animated Series where he's more like -
do you know he's more kind of pom-pom
and circumstance and he looks very put
together and very like you know high-end
and very luxurious that's kind of how
his character comes across but then you
think about what the penguin would
actually be like in a city like Gotham
City and it's like no he would be an
absolute disaster and that's how clay
man draws him and it's just kind of cool
to see you know it's kind of interesting
and Halle Quinn basically tells him look
like I have everybody coming after me
right now
this is one of the most important parts
of the story it's parthis worse - next
that's why Tom King is so cool
so Tom King so the way this plays out is
it's basically like like it's this kind
of discussion back and forth Superman's
like that man you know Batman's like no
I don't know and one woman's like you're
Batman of course
you know what's going on here like you
know how this guy died and Batman picked
it up right off the bat you know you
have this guy with with indestructible
skin and the whole stance is well
somebody put something in his mouth I
mean if you can't if he's basically like
Luke Cage you can't really pierce his
skin then somebody put something in his
mouth they made him swallow it and
that's what ended up killing him and
it's kind of crazy because Batman
figuring this out so fast you know leads
to two men and one woman asking
questions of Batman himself like you're
the guy who prepares for everything
you're the guy who always has an ace up
his sleeve you're the guy who's always
got secrets like you use this place like
you can't tell us otherwise you use this
place to spy on people like sure this
was a place where it where very people
could go and they could seek out refuge
and they could spill their darkest
secrets so they wouldn't have to carry
those around but you built a backdoor so
you could watch them so you could see
what it was that they do now this is
really like Superman to wonder one's
kind of throwing things out there and
really like speculating more so than
anything else but it makes sense about
man would do that that was the whole
basis of tower Babel tower Babel
established the Batman had these
protocols on how to take down each
member the Justice League did he never
told anybody about the entire Justice
League felt betrayed by Batman and it's
like these offhand remarks well know
you've probably got like kryptonite in
your bat belt there's something like
that in Batman's like that's ridiculous
of course I don't it's these cool little
exchanges because what this does is it
throws in the sharp relief the idea that
the Justice League doesn't fully trust
Batman but then we actually know finding
out Batman himself went to sanctuary
Batman goes and sits down in the chair
and see this Tom King man it's nine
panels long and it tells you so much
about Batman right like he sits down in
the chair
and he says I've trained partners to
work with me and they've become my
family and then some of them have died
and that's it that's all you get and he
just sits there and then he breaks down
and cries and he says I'm sorry and it's
just like holy SH it's one of the
coolest things about like people who
love Batman will tell you one of the
coolest things about Batman and maybe
you have to be a Batman fan to really be
able to grasp but it's like this is the
guy who never tells anybody anything
it's like this incredibly human side of
Batman that you never get to see but
from this point forward we pick up with
Booster Gold now
Booster Gold is is one of those guys
who's as much goofy as anything else
like he's as much kind of a hassle as
anything else because remember he's
basically a fraud right he's a guy that
never did anything with his life he got
tired travel powers or time travel
technology jet to the 20th century and
he's like yeah in my time I'm a hero
I'm Booster Gold and just kind of like
hoodwinked his way on to being part of
like Justice League International and
and so on and so forth but he's a guy
who's more apt to screw things he screw
things up then he has to do
he's right and so actually I kind of
take things that are out of order a
little bit because what you end up doing
is kind of jumping back and forth
between Harley Quinn and booster who
actually got to kind of clear this up
because the two are separate and they
don't really cross over here but when is
it happening is booster sits around and
says okay so like I'm probably the one
who did this Harley Quinn tells me I'm
the one who did this and I'm pretty sure
I'm the one who did this so I'm not
really gonna tell anybody that I'm the
one who did this but I'm gonna solve the
crime so that once people find out that
I did it well I'm also the guy who
solved everything so they'll just say
hey you know six in one hand a half
dozen the other and and we'll go ahead
and let it go that's how boosters that's
that's like a classic Booster Gold thing
I screwed up really bad here but I fix
what I screwed up so that means
everybody will forget that I screwed up
in the first place it's pretty classic
of his character and so when he goes
through and he starts thing he's like
okay well there were bodies strewn
everywhere so that of course the first
thing we have to do is figure out you
know who knows about these bodies you
know he's like if anybody in the world
knows about bodies it's Barry Allen so
I'll run to Barry Allen's here Barry
Allen what's going on I keep in mind
Barry Allen doesn't know about sanctuary
at least not to the extent that Booster
Gold does and for those are guys you saw
issue number one you guys know if you
guys read that you guys know what Barry
Allen doesn't know and so when you have
Booster Gold show up here and start
talking to Barry and say hey man look I
need you to tell me what's been going on
like like give me the information you
did about the autopsies with the bodies
of sanctuary there he's like what the
hell are you talking about the whole
time he's fighting something he's like
what the hell are you talking about he's
like you member what happened man like
you know what happened like everybody is
sanctuary died and like Barry doesn't
know he had no clue that Wally West died
and the whole time Skeets the robot of
Booster Gold like dude shut the hell up
stop talking because if you do you're
gonna spill the beans to Barry and he's
gonna lose it and the whole time that
that boosts are saying is he's like I
mean I'm pretty sure I'm the one who did
it you know and so just by connecting
the simplest of dots hey Wally wes is
dead it's sanctuary and I'm pretty sure
I'm the one who killed him Barry
races off like he's he's um he's out in
the time it takes for who should have
finish his sentence Barry is there and
backing him and he even asks Keyes like
how long do you think it'll take him to
analyze the bodies and get back to say
well considering he's the fastest man
alive probably pretty quickly and and
Barry comes running in with with the
wrath of God and just punches the hell
out of Booster Gold while he's crying
into screaming what did you do it's so
cool it's why I left Tom caked on keys
amazing at riding heroes and when he
rises like it's the super emotional
Barry out because he basically had the
the the beans spilled on him by a guy
who didn't fully grasp the reality
situation who just kind of fly
by the seat of his pants being a
superhero and really doesn't seem to be
very cavalier about throwing that then
information out there to Barry which is
kind of surprising considering how much
Booster Gold knows about Barry and so
when that informations thrown out there
Barry is an emotional wreck and
absolutely loses it and who the hell
knows what'll happen after this and so
picking up with Harley Quinn Harley
Quinn and turn is playing go fish with a
penguin which it's Harley Quinn nobody
ever said she was sane so it's a Harley
Quinn playing go fish with a penguin
enough said
which leads to the arrival of like
Superman Batman in one room the Trinity
basically bust into the scene and say
hey look we have questions we need to
talk and Harley just like like it's
almost like she prepared for this
because she basically says look like
it's crazy and there were bodies
everywhere and it's kind of like losing
your mind you know it's just oh my god
it was so insane and it was just this
overwhelming thing it makes your way up
to Wonder Woman which is a smart move
because Wonder Woman will be more likely
to forgive Harley Quinn and then Batman
or Superman
because remember Wonder Woman sees the
various female superheroes out there as
her sisters so she's not going to just
automatically lash out she's gonna
listen first but but this is the cool
thing
Harley Quinn makes her way up to Wonder
Woman and when she does she snatches the
lasso of truth steals it off of Wonder
Woman and in turn uses her acrobatics
jumps out of the way knocks Wonder Woman
out and then lashes it around Batman
take some hostage and this is cool
because Harley Quinn knows Batman like
she knows how Batman functions will she
wraps it around him
she literally asked the question is
there anything that you have on you
right now that can be used against the
Justice League and Batman's responses
you know like like that like seems like
no he doesn't you know he told me he
does and one woman's like no this is you
know no one wants to believe the
Batman's response there's kryptonite my
bat Bell it's in the fourth powder in
the third pouch on the left and it's in
a lead container damn Batman's a liar
lied to Superman right to his face and
Wonder Woman had to have suspected it
because she's not into now she's not
like oh my god really did you just kinda
like Batman yet again more lies more
trickery from The Dark Knight and in
turn like she grabs the kryptonite
breaks it out you know uses it as an as
a way to distract Superman and just
races off and she's got Wonder Woman in
turn of course turns to Superman chairs
to Batman to tend to him to make sure
they're okay because she would take the
more logical stances they do be time to
catch up to her later which gives Harley
Quinn D out that she needs but this is
yet another instance where Batman is
lying to the Justice League lying to his
friends this same thing as always Batman
lying Batman being deceitful
you know and Superman kind of brushes it
off in the moment but it's also one of
these things worse like I guess it's
kind of kind
expected meal but like the same as he
makes here he knows like man she's good
you know she's as good as you are Batman
she's as good as you at tricking people
lying to people it's kind of crazy
because Wonder Woman is just like this
is not the time for this this is not the
time to get into a pissing contest and
to argue and bicker and so on and so
forth and then suddenly Superman picks
up on what's going on that Barry Allen
has Booster Gold the Barry Allen
mistaken Booster Gold which means Barry
Allen now Xena now knows what's going on
and so this is when you basically pick
up with Harley Quinn which is on the top
of a bridge in Gotham and she she starts
talking about sanctuary and this is a
cool thing because what she says here is
she says I shouldn't have done all the
things that I've done like there's so
many things that I shouldn't have done
she says I shouldn't have let anyone
hurt you
I shouldn't have followed you to
sanctuaries like I should not have led
to let anyone kill you poison ivy I
shouldn't have told you about sanctuary
I shouldn't have loved you and I
shouldn't have met you you know I
shouldn't have done all the things that
led up to this moment
basically that poison ivy was told about
sanctuary and so it seems as though
sanctuary had an open doors policy they
they you didn't have to be invited they
that it wasn't only a limited number of
people it was for anyone which lives up
to the Charter of sanctuary as it had
been explained so far anybody can come
in here and anybody can confess their
sins that's what this place is for and
so it's kind of nuts because then you
switch over to The Daily Planet and
there's this package that came in for
Lois Lane like it's basically written by
arsenal saying here's the whole basis
behind sanctuary here's what this whole
place is about here's what we do here
here's how all this stuff works and if
any of us should die here just know that
it was done by the peddlers you know at
least the package itself was signed by
the puddlers and so it's just kind of
like wow I mean like there's these these
hidden hands behind all this and so this
is when things get really really really
crazy because if every because here's
the thing you have to remember all these
confessions are being made to computer
systems and if these confessions are
being made to computers then it stands
to reason that all the information would
be delete it that's what Batman says in
the story no no no you know this whole
thing is there people confess their sins
in 24 hours it's deleted so you can say
anything you want to what you have here
is you ask Superman who sits down and
says I'm Superman I'm Clark Kent I was
raised as the Kenton in Smallville and
then I learned my own history I learned
the fact that I came from that I come
from Krypton that in the presence of a
Yellow Sun that I have what amount to
basically godly powers and that I lead a
dual identity sometimes I don't really
know who I am sometimes I don't know if
I'm really Clark Kent or if I'm really
Superman and that's why I made the
identity so similar to each other by
just taking off these glasses and
putting them back on because if I made
them too extreme I would get lost in my
identities I wouldn't know who I
actually was but it's something that he
fears
it's something that he's afraid of that
he'll lose his way but Superman just
confessed his identity to a recording
device that could very well have been
infiltrated and could very well have
been taken over now but do you know to
what happens to this recording device I
have no real idea I mean it'll probably
come out through their identities and
reveal to the world and so on and so
forth but in terms of who it was that
killed everyone in reality if I'm if I'm
a betting man I would say this is being
done by psycho-pirate because from from
wine from what we gather we don't know
what happened to cyclopath I mean we
know we don't really know the last time
we saw psycho-pirate was during Tom
Kings Batman one of the IM suicide story
and like psycho-pirate was serving
alongside Bane and then psycho-pirate
was taken by Batman in order to undo the
damage that was done to Gotham girl but
then like thats it like like as far as
we're aware him he wasn't killed he's
not dead he's just out there somewhere
and it's entirely possible that if
Batman sits down and Batman says let's
create sanctuary then Batman would have
to answer the question what do we do
with those who don't want to talk like
those who come here but then they they
they get hesitant and they walk away how
do we get them to talk and psycho-pirate
can do that he manipulates the emotions
of others but it would it would makes
perfect sense to me that psycho-pirate
is the man standing on the other side of
these recording devices the recording
devices are just recording devices but
who knows but like I feel like psycho
Caribbean would have a hand in all this
that you'd be there Hubie what amounts
to the therapist the person manipulating
you know emotionally manipulating people
into letting all their all their
emotions out either that it would be
like psycho prior and Hugo Strange who
were like Hugo Strange is in the shadows
behind the scene manipulating
psycho-pirate or controlling
psycho-pirate telling him what to do
psycho-pirate does that and no one knows
that Hugo Strange is behind it all
there's a lot of things it could be
going on here the only reason why I even
think about Hugo Strange I think about
that old story from from Batman the old
Steve Englehart run which they did in
Batman the atom in a series where he go
strange was was basically learning
people's like darkest secrets and then
blackmailing them and like paying him
money or doing in political favors you
know again there's any number of things
that could go on here okay so getting
into heroes in crisis part 3 what I want
to do here is I want to kind of switch
up how we would normally record this
we're just to say normally we would go
through the way the books written and
kind of call it a day the issue with
this is that the way the Tom King does
this is this literally like the first
page is lagoon boy the second page is is
Wally West the third page is like
Booster Gold and then it goes back to
lagoon boy then it goes back to what all
unity goes back to Booster Gold and so
what it does is it would create all
kinds of weird issues when we're trying
to record this and so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna split it into segments
because really it focuses on these three
characters on wall-e booster and and
Lagoon boy
and the first person I want to focus on
here is the segment about Lagoon boys
character now as he's going through here
he's basically being shot with a laser
consistently but remember the nature of
of sanctuary is that it's designed to be
a place of healing a place for people to
kind of move on past whatever struggles
they have and then go back to being a
hero you know it's kind of like a rehab
clinic to a degree but more more like a
trauma clinic now the important thing
about this is that with lagoon boys
seeking this out on himself
initially we didn't really know why this
was happening but then Tom King goes
through and kind of gives us an
explanation about lagoon boy and
actually draws on on former instances of
his character and so the sort of uh to
sort of wind the clock back a little bit
you know what Lagoon boy tells us here
is that as he's as he's doing this what
he's doing is hearing the screams of
various members of the Titans that he
had fought alongside and who were
severely injured in in a variety of
different ways you know for example one
of the characters power boy was injured
he hears you know he hears his screams
in his mind he hears the screams of like
a carrot aname Barda what this does is
it kind of goes back to the to the
origin of lagoon boy and then the
attempts of DC to like branch off the
team Titans title 1 o'clock back to 1998
there was a guy named Erik Larsen who
took over the Aquaman series now Erik
Larson's Aquaman run I was written after
Peter David and a lot of Aquaman fans
hated the Erik Larson run but in reality
it wasn't really Erik Larson's fault
Riley here was more of like an editorial
mandate which is to say that under Peter
David the writing of Aquaman was was
pretty dark and it was pretty
heavy-handed and so coming out of that
it was make Aquaman lighter and the
result was that in a lot of ways the run
of Erik Larson came off as kind of campy
now Lagoon boy was introduced in issue
number 50 and the idea was to form a
group that was called the surface lovers
I think it was what it was called um but
basically it was it was lagoon boy and a
couple of the people who essentially
took to kind of like going against
Atlantean ways and then just kind of
being more of like a bridge kind of
serving their role as Aquaman where
they're kind of like a bridge between
the surface world in Atlantis of course
didn't take too well with the Atlantean
people but for a lagoon boy himself he
actually has no origin in DC Comics as
far as I'm aware he was just there one
day and the reason why no origin was
given if I were a betting man I would
say is because you know the run of Eric
Larsen wasn't very well received which
means that Lagoon boy was not very well
received now that goes into the teen
titans special which I want to say was
written by Chuck Dixon although I could
be wrong but it was Teen Titans East and
Teen Titans East was designed to take
the normal Teen Titans team and then
create like a secondary team that would
basically function in a different
capacity
but would still follow the Teen Titans
bran would still have team LTH
superheroes but basically you had this
this New Teen Titans team that was
formed and then like right off the bat
they go against the kids a Trigon who
basically wrecked them all and that's
the experience that Lagoon boys talking
about when he talked about hearing their
screams and different things like that
being shot with a laser you know and so
on and so forth that's what he's
enduring here he's constantly doing it
to himself and the reason why is because
with a laser passed to him and put him
in a comatose state so on and so forth
his idea is if he endures being shot
enough times eventually it won't affect
him anymore and so the screams will stop
in his head that's the kind of treatment
he's going with here now that's the
important thing about sanctuary its
sanctuary does not really seem to have
any true doctors which is to say it's
not as where they go in there and then
they're diagnosed and then they say
here's what you need to do to fix your
problem instead they go in there and it
is kind of left to their own devices and
they stay however long they need to stay
until that trauma is essentially
remedied which as you guys can imagine
can cause all kinds of different
problems and that's what Lagoon boy
indoors is constantly being shot with
lasers now of course there comes a point
where somebody says stop I'll come back
tomorrow and we'll continue the process
again but that's basically what he's
doing is literally injuring himself
under the idea but eventually he'll
become immune to it or it won't faze him
anymore it won't bother him anymore and
the belief is that when that time comes
he won't have to worry about the voices
in his head or anything like that now
switching over to wally west things are
a lot more straightforward here one of
the things to bear in mind when it comes
to to classic wally west is that he's
been stuck in the speedforce all this
time when the events of new 52 happened
and everything was rebooted and classic
wally west was nowhere to be found when
rebirth started DC answer the question
of where's classic Wally West Bend by
saying he's been stuck in the Speed
Force and Barry Allen was finally able
to bring him out by remembering him and
so ever since then
classic Wally has been getting his
memories back slowly and steadily and
that means he's been learning about his
children joy and iris he's been learning
about Linda Park the fact that they were
married but that's not the case now you
know by whatever man and whatever means
presumably do the actions of dr.
Manhattan everything Wally West knows
has been changed and so where he can't
just run to Linda Park and say hey we're
married and we have kids and expect her
to kind of be on board like oh that
makes sense
if that's not gonna happen and so what
he's been doing here is basically trying
to like figure out or at least try to
find somebody to kind of cope with his
existing environment and so what we end
up finding out is that what he's been
doing is basically recreating his life
inside of sanctuary where he has Linda
Park who runs out to greet him where he
has his kids giant iris he has the life
he always won
and so one of the cool things is that he
and his kids the tornado twins actually
end up facing off against Captain cold
and that's kind of like reliving the
memories reliving the way things used to
be now in reality this is a good way of
coping with things but I feel like what
Tom King is hitting at here is that this
can be a very very dangerous thing and
the reason why is because there is such
a thing as getting lost in any scenario
that we're in there's only ever two
circumstances that we face the reality
as things are and the way we would like
them to be and oftentimes if we allow
ourselves to get stuck in the way that
we would like them to be we get trapped
there we never fully recover like we
never come back from there right because
I mean it's like why would you it's like
Star Trek the Star Trek generations
right well the movie was terrible they
had this really really cool concept
called the ribbon and basically if it
passed over you you were yanked into a
place called the Nexus and you
essentially repeated the best moments of
your life presumably for all eternity or
at least for however long your body held
out but if you if you were given the
opportunity to relive the best moments
of your life why wouldn't you take that
opportunity and if you were given that
opportunity and you did take it what's
to say you wouldn't get lost and that's
the issue with Wally West here Wally
West is living in a life that doesn't
exist anymore and living in this life
that doesn't exist anymore he won't want
to leave or at least it seems like he
won't want to leave and so in response
to that how can you yank somebody from
perfection
how can you yank somebody from absolute
tried and true happiness this is the
life he always wanted he has his wife he
has his kids he has the things that he
lost that he wants back so dear but the
problem is that he's not facing the
reality of the situation the reality
situation is that his his family's
basically gone and maybe it's one of
these things where if it had been
allowed to play out the Tom Keane would
have written it out in such a way to
where Wally West would have just been
able to say goodbye I have to let you go
I remember Wally is Wally was told by
Professor zoom you know he was told
hey like your kids are alive like your
kids are in live and they exist out
there somewhere so Wally is most likely
on the hunt for them or will be on the
hunt for them at some point in time but
it's one of the interesting things
because the way this is written it
almost seems to kind of ignore that idea
right like it almost seems to kind of
ignore the notion that Wally's aware of
his children's true existence because
when the question would be if he does
know they exist why isn't he out finding
him so again you know these these little
tidbits are kind of you know a little
bit of a little bit of conflict going on
there but nothing outrageous you know
it's just kind of Wally living this life
that ultimately it doesn't seem like
he'll want to let go up now for Booster
Gold
his segment of the story is a lot more
straightforward he's a guy trying to
figure out what in the heck is going on
but here's the issue with this
Booster Gold has always had two parts to
himself right like there's the Booster
Gold as the hero and the Booster Gold
who's a liar the Booster Gold for me as
he exists like he's basically a conman
right like you took technology from the
future travel to the past and is like
I'm the greatest hero in the future and
it just kind of purported that idea in
the present day the issue with that is
that boosters been living without
lighting entire time that's less kind of
a thing like what he goes through we
kind of get this explanation of what's
going on with regards to the nature of
of sanctuary in the sense that when this
issue first opened up and Booster Gold
first arrived at sanctuary he was met by
basically what appeared to be mom talk
hint in Lana Lang
now the inclusion of them is not
accidental sanctuary itself was built
using the technology of Superman the
ingenuity of Batman and the hope of
Wonder Woman but when it comes to the
character of MA and POC hint in Lana
Lang they hold a very particular place
in DC Comics not just with Superman but
with DC Comics as a whole and what I
mean by that is that is that Jonathan
and Martha can't kind of represent the
greater wisdom that people kind of
impose these pearls of wisdom on us that
was a nature of ma of Jonathan and
Martha Kent helping Superman become more
than just a guy with powers and become
something that represented hope for
Humanity Lana Lang plays a very
important role because she was the first
person to recognize or to learn the
powers of Superman and taught him how to
use them so she was very much kind of
like a younger guiding hand for Clark
Kent as opposed to the the pearls of
wisdom that were instilled on him too I
Jonathan and Martha Kent but with the
nature of sanctuary itself what it does
is it basically changes your environment
using Kryptonian crystals and that
allows you to use whatever you need to
do in order to get past things for
Booster Gold he's facing himself that
Booster himself has a lot of unresolved
issues here now these aren't really
delved into too far in this you know
it's just kind of like hey basically
everything you do screws up why well
because you're not doing it for good
reasons you're doing it because you're
trying to prove that you're an actual
hero and that's the nature of Booster
and those are the two diets those two
diametrically opposed views that his
character represents on one half you
have Booster Gold who wants to be the
hero and on the other half you have
Booster Gold doing everything to show
he's a hero when in reality he's not
he's a conman he doesn't think like a
good guy he thinks like how can I prove
that I'm a hero by doing this he's
basically trying to fix what's not
broken and so what that does is it
creates all kinds of problems for his
character now before any of this goes on
before we really get any a Theo huge
explanation on what's happening with
these guys suddenly alarms start going
off and when they do lagoon boys
he's one of the people that's killed
Wally races out only to find that of
course red arrow arsenal whatever you
want to call him Roy Harper is basically
dead and the person over looking at all
is Harley Quinn and Harley Quinn tracks
Wally West over the head without with a
mallet and kills Wally West and so as
it's kind of like okay well then Harley
Quinn of course you know was one who
killed Wally presumably is the one who
seems to have killed everybody else it's
kind of intriguing and it's kind of
interesting because we don't really know
exactly what direction things are going
and it's one of these scenarios where as
kind of like vantage point right like
all these things are happening but we're
looking at it from different
perspectives trying to figure out who
the who's ultimately responsible for the
death of all these characters okay so
picking up with heroes in crisis part
for god we're kind of behind uh we need
to get caught out like I let everybody
in the comic book YouTube scene get
ahead of me now I have to crush them all
with my uploads okay so getting into
heroes in crisis part four so this is
all right this is kind of cool because
one of the things to bear in mind again
kind of getting back into this this here
is a crisis thing this is designed to
show the side of the superheroes that we
don't see right so like it's really
familiar it's really similar to like
civil war or those you guys who never
read Marvel Civil War of course was a
big calamity the superheroes versus
superheroes but what made it cool was
you saw like small little moments where
there were different heroes like t rare
who were like I cannot afford to be a
college kid and a superhero at the same
time with my identity out there in the
world and if I have to choose one I'll
choose to go to college and so like they
would quit and so it was like these
small little things and that's what's
cool about heroes in crisis initially
this picks up with like tempest who's
basically drunk in a bar and just kind
of rambling on and going on about
nonsense
it's not designed to really say like
he's under like a huge shock or anything
like that it's designed to show these
heroes at their worst when they're at
their lowest points because what this is
designed to do what the whole concept of
hero in crisis is designed to do is to
humanize the heroes even more than they
already are to basically say like
whenever you go and buy a Batman book
all you see is Batman fighting one
villain after another but what happens
between the panel's like what happens
between these issues what step is doing
what Superman doing what's Batman doing
what are they doing between these
conflicts how are they coping with like
all these major events that are going on
and so on and so forth that's what is
designed to focus on and that's why it's
so cool because what we end up doing
here is we switch over to Booster Gold
now remember Booster Gold was the person
who was basically on the scene when like
the whole event of really like the
deaths of all these superheroes went on
during sanctuary you know he woke up
early Quinn was there but as far as
everybody's
where they believe that Booster Gold was
the one to do it and so what he ends up
doing is basically taking this kind of
lasso test where one woman puts a lasso
around his hands and where he basically
divulges everything he saw and what he
says really kind of it's really cool for
tom kean to do this because it kind of
catches this up but what he says is
basically like I was there I made a
confession just like everybody else and
then like all hell broke loose and
that's basically it like as far as I
know Harley Quinn was the one who did it
because like I came out there and like
everybody was dead Harley Quinn had this
bleeding mallet and then she started
hitting me with it and then I woke up
later on and that's it that's all he
really knows I mean that's one of the
things to bear in mind is that when it
comes to Booster Gold he's kind of the
perfect culprit to blame if you're the
person who committed all these acts
remember boosters entire superhero
antics are shrouded in fraud he's a guy
from the future who dreamed of being a
superhero after beating being basically
a nobody he stole a whole bunch of
Technology from a museum he traveled
back to the present day and said I'm a
hero from the future once that was found
out he was just kind of like okay
whatever this guy is not really much of
a hero at all but he still kind of went
along and did various hero antics but he
was just kind of like the class clown
the goofball the one who's more inclined
to screw things up than to get things
right and so if you're a person who's
gonna commit a crime no one sees what it
is that you've done and Booster Gold
happens to be there he's a perfect guy
to blame and so this is when the plot
thickens because what we do here is we
switch over to to Lois Lane speaking
with Superman you know talking to Clark
Kent and what she basically reveals here
is that she's been getting information
she's basically be getting the video
files these confessions that people have
been making they've been sent directly
to her now she of course is kind of
operating under the assumption that if
they've been sent to her they've been
sent to other people but remember Lois
Lane is a reporter and so for her it's
the story that really seems to count and
that's one of the kind of things that
that honking really draws here is he
almost kind of draws this idea that for
Lois Lane it's the story first and then
everything else second but it's not
necessarily that way because the case
she makes here is someone's gonna drop
this scoop my source gave me these files
the implication seems to be that
somebody else or other people have the
files or or could get the files besides
her source or at the very least her
source got the files in such a way to
where they could be leaked to the public
and so her idea is we have to make this
story public and we have to make it fast
because if we don't somebody else will
do it before I do and they won't be
unbiased don't put a slant on it and
it'll be things like are superheroes
trustworthy are superheroes good guys
you know they'll do it in such a way to
where it has a political leaning where I
as Lois Lane can do it in the most non
slant way possible as that's why it's
one of the cool things that kind of goes
on here is
it's the question of does Lois Lane have
a moral obligation to publish the story
given its very nature in the fact that
if somebody else does it they'll do it
in and what could be it could be a
negative way it's possible they could do
it in a positive way but remember when
it comes to the superheroes in DC Comics
there's a lot of negative slant sources
they're not inherently bad and it's not
like society as a whole views them as a
negative but it's one of these things
where the news exists to sell itself and
so if the news can be sold in such a way
to where it could be done in a negative
fashion and people will eat it up more
likely than they would be if it were
done in a positive fashion then that's
what they will do and so again it's kind
of a funny scenario because and what you
end up doing is picking up with Batgirl
and Harley Quinn and the two of them
literally just start immediately coming
to blows now there's a couple reasons
for this one because it's Harley Quinn
and Batgirl and two because Harley
Quinn's basically on the run here that
seems to be the indication throughout
this whole story is she's essentially
like fleeing for life because for those
who have been investigating this whole
thing and those who are looking past
Booster Gold as the immediate suspect
that makes Harley Quinn public enemy
number one it makes her the number one
suspect so she was quite literally
caught with blood on her hands with the
whole thing that was going on in
sanctuary and she'll with Batgirl
showing up here of course the kind of
discussion was look you know I'm not
really here to bust you or anything like
I'm here to help you I'm here to try to
figure out what's going on so on and so
forth I so the two of them kind of kind
of calmed down and and sort of Hagen and
go from there but it's kind of
interesting here because what that sums
up doing is is sort of switching over to
Blue Beetle and this is kind of a cool
little thing here because remember Blue
Beetle in Booster Gold they're two peas
in a pod they're the best of friends and
one of the things that really gets
talked about here with Blue Beetle is is
that exact thing when Ted Kord is going
through here and he's talking about
these different concepts one of the
things that he hits on is his friendship
with Booster Gold and that's why he says
like I put Booster Gold first like I
trust Booster Gold if he says he didn't
do it then I believe him but it's a very
important thing here because as he goes
through and kind of talks he talked
about the nature of what it means to be
a hero right like you're effectively
surrounded by death and suffering all
the time that's the nature of what it
means to be a superhero is that heroes
yell various heroes die all the time and
that's why the story is so cool is
because DC Comics on the whole largely
focuses on like the popular heroes the
cool kids table that's basically DC you
don't really see what goes on in like
the band geek table or like the comic
book nerd table you don't really see
what goes on on those little tables over
there but we're kind of left to assume
that their heroes they do things and
some stuff happens and they sort of go
about their business and they go to bed
and then all I kind of good stuff you
don't really hear their story you don't
see which of which one of them died you
don't see which one of them loose
you never really learned about that with
Blue Beetle here he's kind of like that
happens all the time like in that table
over there they lost four or five guys
in the last three weeks you look at that
table over there well they've lost ten
guys in the last year but you never hear
that story but when he says he's a super
hero he's sitting at the tables just
like everybody else surrounded by all
these different tables of all these
different heroes some come and some go
and it's just the nature of the beast
and it's kind of like how do you get
past that how do you learn to cope with
it and the response he gives is it's
just the way it goes
it's just kind of it's just the nature
of the beast how this whole thing
happens is that's why he says when
things get hard and things get tough
Booster Gold is the one that he goes to
and that's why it's kind of cool because
for all the benefit that cord industries
does in terms of providing a kind of
financial back end to the building of
sanctuary to a lot of different things
that go on at the end of the day Booster
Gold and and really Blue Beetle are
still kind of considered to be outliers
they're heroes but they're not really
heroes you know what I mean like they're
not really part of the Justice League
like through there but when people say
oh my god we got to get ahold of Justice
League nobody thinks of Blue Beetle
nobody things our Booster Gold they're
just kind of heroes who were there and
like these serve a purpose occasionally
even in the real world reading comic
books is kind of an on running joke the
most significant moment in Ted kord's
life was getting shot in the head like I
mean it's just one of those things that
you kind of get with when it comes to
comics isn't as sort of the guys who
were down there and so that's why things
get sort of crazy is because what
happens here is we basically pick up
with Superman when he's speaking
directly with Batman and Wonder Woman
now remember they're the ones who made
sanctuary right like sanctuary uses the
technology of Superman in terms of the
you know the the they'll available
technologies and the fortress of
solitude they can create like Holograms
illusions different things like that so
it uses that technology with regards to
creating like Holograms and so on coping
mechanisms different things like that it
uses the ingenuity and the money of
Batman in terms of how to pull it all
together and of course it's all based on
the empathy of Wonder Woman and her
ability to like understand other
people's pain so between the Trinity
they have effectively built sanctuary
and so it makes sense that with things
popping off the three of them are
talking but Superman shows up here in
says look there's something that I have
to make you guys aware of and then the
question is what they know the response
is Lois Lane is gonna go live with a
story about sanctuary
she has all the the various data logs
now of course Batman's response is
that's not possible they should all be
gone and deleted and remember that makes
sense because what you're talking about
here are confessions of superheroes and
no one knows what they're gonna say
when Wonder Woman did her confession she
talked about killing Maxwell Lord when
Superman did his confession he talked
about dying when Batman at his confess
he talked about having his back broken
by Bain these are the innermost thoughts
of people at sent of various superheroes
being recorded on these data logs things
they would never share with the world
things they don't want anybody else to
know their deepest darkest desires their
deepest darkest confessions all are
being made on these data log tapes and
that's why they're supposed to be
deleted almost right off the bat so that
nobody can ever get their hands on them
but what seems to have happened here is
by one means or another someone got
their hands on all these different video
tapes and when the question is asked
when is Louis going live with the story
Superman says well that's why I'm
telling you it went live 33 seconds ago
and so it's just like wow so so
basically like all this information is
now out there about the superhero
community all these confessions are now
out there is literally throwing
everything out there into the world and
taking all the deepest darkest secrets
especially with Batman when Batman's
disasters like I've had a desire to kill
heroes before I have I've had a desire
to eliminate them to destroy them to
wipe them off the face of the earth but
I can't do that because I go it goes
against everything I stand for like what
those confessions being being made and
thrown out there they're available for
the world to see we're just going to
fundamentally change how the world views
superheroes okay so continuing on with
heroes in crisis part 5 this really
deals more with like the aftermath and
it's almost kind of like Superman's
appeal to humanity now there are a
couple things that go on here but again
there's really really like two big
takeaways from all this there's only
really like like two big moments from
from this whole thing but I like the way
that this is done because I feel like
Tom King uses the nature of Superman so
exceedingly well so when it comes to
Superman in in DC Comics this is a very
important thing to remember here
Superman is a contextual character and
what that means is that people's
enjoyment of Superman comics is relative
to how he's written and while you would
normally say that about a bunch of other
heroes for the most part you can really
get away with a lot of things with a lot
of different heroes with Batman you can
tell really dark and gritty stories like
Batman in game and you can even go back
to Steve Englehart where the Joker was
like dark and comedic and you can go
into those those different aspects Teen
Titans you can do a lot of teenage drama
or you could do happier stories there's
a lot of shifting around that goes there
but for Superman he's not really that
flexible and the reason why is because
of how long he's been around and what he
stands for
Mark Waid this is really really good
interview years ago it was this was
probably a little maybe 10 years ago and
what he said was the reason why Superman
is so popular why he stands the test of
time is because he's everything to
like every generation Superman is
whatever that generation needs him to be
so like during the 60s when it was all
anti Vietnam war in the hippie movement
was that it's at the height of its
popularity
Superman was kind of a reflection of
that he was anti-war it was it was
always that way it's always been that
way with his character that's kind of
how he maintains his relevance and so
one of the worst things you can do with
Superman is try to kind of like force
him into a role that's just not very
appealing that's not really in the
nature of its character but Tom King
does that exceedingly well and so one of
the funny things about this is that it
initially picks up with like the really
kind of the aftermath of this article
published by Lois Lane being sent out to
the world basically showing like all
these revelations and all these
statements and all these admissions and
different things like that there were
all brought to bear by the various
superheroes who were out there making
their admissions within the confines of
sanctuary and so in response to the
Superman immediately addresses the crowd
and there's a reason why it's Superman
the in the universe landscape in DC
Comics Superman's the most respected
superhero on the planet right like his
word is beyond contest stations that's
the nature of his character that's the
nature of how he functions within you
know on earth within DC Comics is this
like the one guy you don't question and
it's the one hero that like everyone has
respect for the villains respected in
the heroes respective even if they don't
like him even if they fight him all the
time they still respect him and so it
makes sense to parade him out and be the
one that basically says things because
for the most part when you're Superman
shy of somebody running up on you with
kryptonite or like doomsday not really
if you go out there gonna be able to
like challenge you I mean the the number
of people who can legitimately challenge
Superman on earth you can probably count
on one hand and so with that being the
case it's not really like Superman is
much of a challenge so there's not
really a whole lot for him to lose and
so he's just kind of out there talking
to everybody and what he basically says
is that he's prepared a statement for
this whole thing and what he essentially
says here is that like the basis behind
sanctuary is that one he acknowledges
there was an incident that a bunch of
metahumans were killed and that the
prime suspects here are Harley Quinn and
Booster Gold of course if you guys are
curious about that feel free to watch
the previous videos but in response to
this what he basically does you know
while you have like Booster Gold and
Blue Beetle essentially like
investigating the whole crime scene
which we'll talk more about that here in
a minute Superman kind of makes this
statement and basically says the whole
basis behind sanctuary was that it was
supposed to be a place where heroes can
go to essentially recoup from all the
things they've experienced and is
basically Superman saying like these are
just people and that's kind of the cool
thing about it is because from from the
way the comic books are traditionally
and the way the superheroes are
traditionally done they almost seem like
gods among men and for the average
person walking around it'd be different
it'd be difficult to differentiate
between the two and it's kind of a funny
thing because even Batman made that case
and the story the Tom King wrote where
you had Batman serving jury duty and he
was questioned you know Bruce Wayne was
questioning the nature of the Batman
concept and said that people call Batman
God because Batman saves them where God
does not and so if that's the case then
they have to consider Batman God because
if that's not true then how do you
justify a man that says it was this
really cool introspective look at the
character but on the whole across the
board it's usually been done in such a
way that the various superheroes save
the world from multiple threats and
humanity whether they want to admit it
or not looks to those superheroes to
save them and oftentimes forgets the
idea that they are just people that more
often than not with the exception of
Superman Martian Manhunter maybe one or
two other people that they were born on
earth and they were they were born to
parents and their parents raised them to
become productive members of society and
they were just trying to make their way
in the world as best as they possibly
can and people forget that people look
at that they just say like you're a
superhero your job is to save me and if
you don't save me it means you didn't do
your job and the idea behind this is to
say like it was a place of recovery it
was a place of respite it was a place of
the for these people for these heroes to
go and to basically recover from the
various experiences they've had because
I can't bring that to your attention and
they can't bring that to your attention
because that shows weakness Superman I
can't get up there and and basically
start crying and showing all manner
because people will lose faith in him if
you show people that God can bleed they
will lose faith in him like that's
that's the idea behind it is that like
you're Superman or one of these
metahumans got up they're sort of crying
or started showing vulnerability or
emotion that ultimately people would
begin to lose faith in them well if
there's this week of a person how can we
rely on them to save us how can we rely
on them to be there when the times are
the absolute toughest and so with that
being the case they needed a private
place where they could go to they could
spill their darkest secrets they could
tell everything that they ever wanted to
get off their chest and it would
immediately be deleted it would
immediately be removed and that would
never really be the case anymore it's
kind of an interesting thing because
Superman even asked that question
he says if this is a place that people
went to if this is a place that they
went to in order to find some measure of
respite some measure of solace does that
mean that they are now unworthy because
of the fact that they are human they do
need to find some way to let all this
steam off because they're not gods
walking on earth they're just people who
happen to have fantastic powers does
that somehow make them unworthy does it
make them people who are are somehow not
capable of being effective you know
not only that because the fact that it
brings him back down to base level and
because of the fact that returns them to
being perceived as humans in the mind of
humanity while humans are fallible
humans screw up humans do stupid things
people say and do things all the time
that they would normally never say under
any normal circumstance but in the
height of emotion suddenly logic goes
right out the window and when that's the
case how do you in turn justify that
when you've got someone like Superman
what happens to suit if if Lois Lane
dies as Superman has an emotional crisis
well then you run into injustice as well
as best that's the kind of scenario
that's being presented here is what
happens when those who redeemed is
infallible for the power of God suddenly
become fallible and emotional well then
suddenly the world could be turned
upside down the world could just be left
in a total state of catastrophe and
that's the whole point of Superman's
making here and that's why it works so
well is because he basically says these
are people from different countries
different walks of life that I've
watched day in and day out face off
against threats that most of you guys
couldn't even imagine let alone see I've
seen them achieve and insurmountable
things I've seen them do things that
that are that are astronomical I've seen
men and women who can tap into nature
itself I've seen those who can use the
power of animals I've seen gods who
ascend from the oceans in order to try
to make peace with the surface world and
literally try to bridge the gap between
these two things I've met aliens from
outer space I've met other Kryptonians
where I thought I was alone I met all
these different people who come from all
these different facets of what you would
call the superhero community but at the
end of the day there's still just people
they know fear they know love they know
hate they know all these emotions and
because they know all these things it's
easy to be overcome by them and that's
why it's so intriguing and that's why
it's so fascinating is because he says
that was the basis behind sanctuary it
wasn't to manipulate it wasn't a lie it
wasn't a trick it wasn't it to be a
place where they could basically say
like I killed a person and I'm
essentially performing the same act as
like you know confessing to a priest and
now it can't be used against me that's
not the basis behind it it's a place for
those individuals who have powers but
are effectively human to basically deal
with the various torments and nightmares
even do it over the course of their
entire experience in the superhero
landscape and so that's that's so
awesome because what it does is again it
kind of humanizes all these different
superheroes now I've seen a few
complaints here and there's like oh well
you know here goes DC humanizing heroes
again well me yeah it kind of makes
sense to me unless you're saying
Batman's not human so again it's sort of
an interesting concept here to basically
see that kind of worked in and in to
kind of bring them back down because to
me I liked heroes relatable like I like
heroes who are interesting I mean for
all the complaints people will make
about DC's
here they go making heroes relatable
again there's an awful lot of arguments
about how Superman sucks because he's
not relatable so I like all these
different points that are kind of being
made here and it's really really
interesting but one of the big points is
also kind of made is that Booster Gold
basically says because he's a hero who's
so well-versed some time travel he
understands the the basis behind the
rules of time-travel right like in DC
Comics you have a kind of set of
guidelines Riley you have the temporal
authority whatever it is like basically
a police force did make sure that a
person from the future doesn't get time
travel of technology and then starts
screwing up the past and totally
destroying the timestream and so one of
the things Booster Gold says is that in
order to verify how far back a person's
gone in order to see whether or not a
person is actually time travel when they
were supposed to what they would do is
they would take your RNA and they would
compare it to your birthday and if your
RNA was off if your RNA was not 34 years
old and you're actually 34 years old
that's how they would know and Booster
Gold basically being kind of a shady guy
has had to essentially understand this
concept in order to find ways to work
around and so when he and and Blue
Beetle were like investigating all these
different things what they basically
discovered here is that the body of of
Wally West is essentially five days old
that something's not right that there's
something going on in this bigger
picture things aren't really what they
seem to be now Tom King makes this
exceedingly vague he makes us incredibly
vague and he does that intentionally
because we don't really know how this is
gonna go we don't really know where this
rabbit hole leads to but it's really
intriguing and it's actually really cool
because it's one of these things where
like it's effectively Tom King saying
not everything is what it seems to be
not everything is what it appears to be
and again like as the story goes on will
essentially begin to learn more
okay so picking up with yours in crisis
part 6 like a lot of this a lot of the
story that we've seen so far it's kind
of split into sections so we're gonna
kind of take each one of these because
what it does is actually sort of bounces
back and forth between a guy named narc
and then Holly Quinn and then Wally West
so we're gonna kind of take these in
segments but with Harley Quinn like like
hers is really the most straightforward
because what's ironic about this is that
was sanctuary poison ivy had shown up
here presumably for the sake of like
getting help but for the most part
poison ivy just kind of like I'm fine
the way I am this was really more for
Harley Quinn so it's really more that
like she snuck freely Quinn in there
which is kind of a bad guy doing what a
bad guy does I guess but and they're
just behind this really seems to be more
towards kind of leaning towards the idea
that they're really kind of appeared to
be some criminals out there who are just
incorrigible
and that
the indication seems to be that Holly
Quinn was perceived as being one of
those criminals that there was really no
way to help her there was no way to make
her better but the cool thing about this
is that honking kinda hits on the idea
that she's not that far gone what she
needed was the right kind of treatment
and the way this seems to kind of come
about is when poison ivy starts helping
Harley Quinn by basically creating like
these manifestations of the Joker and
what they do is go through and
essentially like torment the Joker and
kill him destroy him that kind of
different thing because that's what the
Joker did to Harley Quinn and that's one
of the things to bear in mind here is
that a lot of those themes that weren't
necessarily hit on you know that were
really hit on the nose in Batman the
Animated Series certainly were in the
comics that the Joker was exceedingly
abusive but Harley Quinn kept coming
back due to some warped perspective of
what love is supposed to be now how how
called Harley Quinn got to that point is
really kind of reflective of whatever
her origin story is right I mean she's
got one origin story and Batman the
Animated Series she's got another origin
story and the actual DC Comics and then
she's got another origin story when she
was rebooted in the new 52 but
throughout all of those the common
themes are basically the Harley Quinn in
some form or fashion was kind of brought
up with it with the victims mentality
with kind of like an abusive mentality
so it's kind of strange the way it all
plays out but again it sort of makes
sense with her character in terms of how
she's progressed so far so like
literally poison ivy is using her her
vines till I killed the Joker like the
Joker's like killing himself basically
like cutting his own throat it's
basically using these things as a means
to kind of help Harley get past the kind
of pain that she's experienced and stop
seeing the Joker is someone that could
legitimately torment her and see the
Joker is somebody who's just easily
killed because a lot of ways the Joker
is the Joker is really like an easily
killable guy the story of Harley Quinn
kind of ends when the alarm bells go off
basically saying like you know there's
an emergency you guys all need to make
their way to the exit because Harley's
not supposed to be there poison ivy
tells her stay here I'm gonna go see
what's going on and then of course as we
know poison ivy dies and so what we end
up doing at this point is we switch over
to two Wally West's now for Wally West
is kind of interesting here because the
big torment of Wally isn't necessarily
like any sort of scenario he's been put
through as a hero with regards to like a
villain he faced it took like an
emotional toll or anything like that
it's being cut off from the world like
that's the torment of Wally West that
when everything happened with flashpoint
and the characters were effectively
rebooted Wally West was stuck in the
Speed Force
so when Barry Allen came out when the
whole reboot finished Barry Allen had
like his whole life and he was so sure
of the life he lived being the right one
with like Donna Troy and Dick Grayson
and all those characters living their
lives they've effectively lived their
lives the way they're supposed to
Wes is suddenly being thrown in here and
because of the fact that like this this
huge event of flashpoint happened and
nobody remembers what happened before
the events of Flashpoint Wally's mindset
being he's one of the few who does
remember is like things aren't the way
they're supposed to be he does he's not
married to his wife he's not married to
Linda Park he can't find giant irises
kids so in his mind like the world's
literally in shambles and for a brief
moment when Barry Allen basically
realized who he was and Barry Allen
brought him back it was kinda like hate
like everything's gonna go back to the
way it was supposed to only for us to
find out that it's not that was kind of
interesting that the lake way Tom King
does this because in reality Tom King
doesn't really do anything to change the
nature of Wally West what he does is he
uses the story to frame the perspective
of Wally West in a slightly different
way that it really is just kind of a
crushing situation that there's no going
back that that's kind of the fear and
really the basis behind Wally West's
life right now he can't go back to the
way things used to be and that's kind of
the cool thing about the the heroes and
crisis story and the nature of Wally is
because when Superman embraces him and
says hey man like your back and when
Nightwing embraces him and Donna Troy
embraces him and and Roy Harper embraces
and they keep saying like your back man
you're the embodiment of hope but the
question that Wally has is how could I
be the embodiment of hope if I'm
hopeless and that's kind of that's kind
of the cool scenario here is things
change the world moves forward you've
got to change with the times it was kind
of a cool little thing because when of
course all that begins to go down when
all that begins to happen basically like
Wally despite the fight the vegies he's
basically surrounded by the Titans
despite the fact that Superman knows who
he is because Superman knows how things
worked before the events of Flashpoint
be it despite the fact that he's
surrounded by like Barry Allen iris West
these people that essentially know who
he is it doesn't change the fact that
Wally West in his entirety feels
completely alone he feels completely
alone and cut off because from his
perspective he's in a world that he
doesn't belong in cuz that's what makes
it kind of crazy is so again it's really
interesting because again like the alarm
bells go off and then it all kind of
comes to a head now again we'll get to
that point here in a second in terms of
what comes next but at this point we
jump back to a character named narc now
narc was a character who originally
appeared back in 1971 by Steve Skeets I
think it was like the guy who created
him up but essentially he's like an
old-school pre-crisis character but
essentially like this version of his
character is kind of reminiscing on how
things were back in the in the early
days of his life
and in the early days of narcs life he
was just like a Neanderthal right like
he was a caveman essentially and what
had happened was that a meteorite had
struck the earth and
fraction of that meteorite some of the
crystal compose inside bonded itself to
him and basically like jump-started his
in his intellect made him super smart
when that happened of course eventually
he was frozen in ice and then basically
he was stuck there for like hundreds and
thousands of years until he was
eventually discovered by like the Teen
Titans being discovered by the Teen
Titans he was essentially let loose and
then like kind of join the team for a
little while and then his fate was never
really specified now in the new 52 we
ended up learning like there was like a
new version of him but again none of
that really ties into like how his
character quote-unquote died according
to Lilith in the in the pre flashpoint
landscape but again at this moment right
now because of the fact that he's so
intelligent he reminisces on characters
like Hobbs and Andrew so now Hobbs is a
is basically talking about Thomas Hobbs
and Thomas Hobbs was his philosopher
that had this really really dark
perspective right like he considered the
nature of humanity to be a perpetual of
permanent war of all against all you had
something called a state of nature
there was no ordered government it was
just kind of humans really more of like
what passes for a nomadic tribes just
kind of making their way but it's
essentially a state of nature no order
government of any con Thomas Hobbes
believed that because resources are
finite that resources basically have to
be preserved but the only way to really
preserve those resources is to create
what was called the Leviathan which is
essentially like in order government
created by whatever society exists at
the time and so again like there are a
lot of other themes that go into it in
terms of like abuses of power
if a king abuses his powers it's just
the way it goes there's really not a
whole lot you can do about that I mean
you could try to overthrow the king but
a new one will take his place and then
he may be just abusive as well it's the
price you pay to maintain some kind of
like order and structure in society that
you can't have it all
but again Thomas Hobbes was very dark
and very very bleak but at the same time
when nark is kind of talking about his
life he says there was a lot of freedom
back then like in the early days of his
life there was a lot of freedom that a
man really just kind of lived by the
sweat of his brow that's all it was you
know that he basically he fought with
nature in order to kind of maintain his
role among nature itself you know and
that's when he kind of begins to go into
jean-jacques Rousseau and jean-jacques
Rousseau is a philosopher who compared
the modern day to the the the state of
nature and basically said state of
nature was better because people had
actual freedom that there really is no
freedom right now there's freedom
insofar as your ability to make
decisions but your ability to make
decisions is predicated based on like
societal structures right so like I'm
going to tweet but I have to make sure I
don't tweet the wrong thing otherwise I
could lose my job ten years later I mean
that is that kind of it's not really
freedom for sake you can't say
anything you want - you can't do
anything you want - you're limited by
like the rules of society by the scope
of the society that you live in and
that's really kind of what it was what
Mark hits at is he had absolute freedom
back then that the only real rules of
society the only real rules of the world
he lived in was survival of the fittest
that he needs to eat
but another Neanderthal needs to eat and
so where he tracks down the kill another
the end of thought will run upon him and
try to take it and basically whoever's
the strongest kills the other and then
gets to feast on the on the on the
animal they killed that was the rule of
nature it was the the law of the land
those who were strong enough to survive
are the only ones who deserve to survive
so again it was it's a little bit darker
but again like there's a lot of a lot of
themes of freedom that go in there and
it's kind of interesting when you look
at it that way because mark kind of has
a point there like back in his early
days it really was just freedom he was
free to do whatever he wanted to to live
his life however he wanted to there were
no bounds there there were no limits
there the only limits imposed on him
were the physical limits of his body at
that point in time the limits of where
he could travel in terms of what's too
cold what's too hot and the limits in
terms of what his mind could comprehend
and that was it
everything else he could do whatever you
wanted to and imagine that kind of
freedom imagine the freedom to go where
you want when you want how you want to
say anything you want to like imagine
that kind of freedom and then compare
that to the modern day and look how free
you really not that was kind of the
argument of jean-jacques Rousseau you're
not really as free as you believe you're
as free as you've been told and so it's
it's really kind of a cool comparison
between these these two different
philosophies but again like you know the
alarm bells go off mark ends up making
his way off and basically says hey look
maybe I'm kind of overthinking it all
but at the same time like that's what
everything kind of begins to unfold
again when like all these different
superheroes end up getting killed on the
grounds of sanctuary and so that's what
we basically end up finding out Booster
Gold was the one who killed Wally West
and presumably Booster Gold was the one
who killed everybody else that seems to
be the case here as was is kind of
interesting because what is what is sort
of hits at is that when Harley Quinn had
shown up there with a blood splattered
mallet that mallet was actually her like
smashing the Joker Alisa seems to be
that she was killing the various
duplicates of the Joker that were being
made in sanctuary as a way to basically
heal her wounds she wasn't actually
going through and killing superheroes
the actual killer here seems to be
Booster Gold so again is pretty
interesting and it and it's really well
I've really liked the direction that
it's taking in terms of how the story is
unfolding okay so we're getting back
into heroes in crisis in part 7 and this
is one of the things I loved a lot about
the heroes in crisis story is this more
of like a philosophical story
and for some people that doesn't really
do it for him right like for some people
they like action-packed stories like
fighting and in the traditional comic
book story kind of kind of tale but the
way this is done by Tom King it's really
more of like a philosophical look at
hero's right like it kind of removes the
action two-degree maine has some in
there but it's more of just the
philosophical look at things and a lot
of this really this the like the biggest
part of this story focuses on Wally West
because of reality like Wally West is
the character that I think a lot of
people are that were at least at the
outset of DC rebirth the most intrigued
in and even during the events of new 52
right like flashpoint happened new 52
kicked off and then Barry Allen was
armed sorry Wally West was nowhere to be
found and everybody wanted to know where
like classic Wally West went we got a
rebooted version of his character but
some fans reject that other fans
embraced it and the result was that on
the whole people were just curious where
the red-haired Wally West win so when he
came back then it was suddenly like okay
well then how do we make this work and
that's really been like the whole nature
of his character and even up until now
even through like Joshua williamson's
flash run all the way up until now this
really kind of seems to be the point
where it focuses the most on like the
experience of Wally after essentially
having come back now there are a couple
of things that go on in here there is
Booster Gold there is Harley it's not
really essential I don't think it may be
that later on it is and if it is and
what kind of come back to it but for the
most part a lot of this focuses on
Batman Barry Allen and then of course
Wally West and initially this kind of
picks up with like Wally West's
introduction into sanctuary the idea
that he's really kind of hopeful here
and that's the cool thing about this is
that you can sort of see this transition
as the story goes on you see this kind
of transition from with Wally West where
he's initially very hopeful and he's
very optimistic in terms of the purpose
of sanctuary conserve right because the
idea of sanctuary was - was supposed to
be a place of respite a place where like
people could go where characters could
go it kind of spilled their deepest
darkest secrets or in some form or
fashion offer a revelation or the very
least cope with the things that caused
them harm in order to find some measure
of peace but it's basically Wally just
kind of coming to coming to terms with
the fact that he's he's here and he's
sort of celebrating the fact that he can
kind of move past all the struggle and
strife that he's endured again we'll
talk about that here in a second but one
of the cool things about this is that
what it does and it kind it kind of
transitions over to Barry Allen and
Batman now remember when it comes to
Batman and Barry Allen Barry Allen is
really kind of on a warpath because of
the fact that Wally West died that's
really kind of why he's playing the role
that he is in heroes in crisis that you
literally had Booster Gold who showed up
and kind of spilled the beans at that
Wally West died and then Bear
has kind of lost his mind right and then
of course Batman's investigating because
it's Batman and so from here it jumps
back in to Wally West again now with
Wally West they're the cool thing here
is that as he starts to go through this
he starts talking about progress and he
starts talking about all these things
that are important to him Linda iris joy
all these individuals but the problem is
that they're all gone and as you look
through this you kind of noticed like
this this difference is this kind of
shift it's not a huge shift but it's
kind of shift he's not as optimistic
anymore he's not as hopeful anymore it's
only his second week but he's not as
hopeful anymore
as time passes he seems to lose more and
more hope but the whole base is behind
us is the fact that everything he knows
is gone right like that's the whole
thing behind Wally imagine for example
that like you woke up tomorrow and like
none of your family knew who you were
everything you know everything of value
to you has vanished no one knows who you
are
now that's the best thing is you that
Wally wes is it now conventional wisdom
would say well then just tell them just
walk up there and just tell them but how
do you tell them that how do you walk up
to a person who as far as they're aware
has never met you has no idea who you
are and say we had a family together
they're gonna think you're crazy
not only that from the perspective of
Wally West one of the things to bear in
mind is he's a tried and true hero and
so when that's the case he kind of has
to ask himself the question is it really
better off for Linda Park to know the
history between herself and Wally
there's no guarantee that she'll do the
same thing iris West did when when Barry
basically revealed everything to Irish
and said hey we were supposed to be
together and when basically iris learned
everything about Wally that hey like I'm
your long-lost nephew or an Indian
basically like I was stuck in the Speed
Force and there's no guarantee that
Linda would react the same way as iris
we're iris embraced Wally Linda could
rebuke him would Wally be able to
withstand that and would it be better
off for Linda or is it better to just
kind of leave her be and so from here
again it kind of shifts back to Batman
and to Barry and they're literally
running through like all the safe houses
that that boosts our gold and that Ted
Kord Blue Beetle usually stay at and
it's kind of a funny little exchange
here like that man's like hey man you
could just use the bat radio like is it
like running all over the place and then
running back every time we visit
somewhere run to Australia run back run
to Berlin run back you can just use the
bat radio and tell me you don't haven't
found anything and Barry's like yeah but
like I'm faster than the bat radio and
Batman's like well I mean I mean I'm not
so sure about that but I guess if it's
done of the right frequencies I could be
wrong for the first time that I'm aware
of in DC Comics Batman admits that he
could be wrong but you know kind of
going into Wally West getting into his
second week here
this is really really cool because what
it does is it kind of refreshes you know
I guess really wall-e is kind of origin
story it's basically explaining
everything about his life and it's kind
of like hey look I was a hero since I
was a teenager I modeled myself after
Barry Allen Barry Allen died and I
became the new flash but the cool thing
about this is Tom King kind of relies on
us as the reader to sort of know these
little these little tidbits of what kind
of goes on behind the scenes right like
you had Barry Allen as as the flash you
ran all the way up until crisis on
Infinite Earths and Wally West was Kid
Flash and then Barry Allen died during
crisis on Infinite Earths or at least he
was believed he died and then during the
events of Final Crisis it was revealed
that he was stuck in the Speed Force but
for all intents and purposes post-crisis
Barry was dead and so during that time
Wally West stepped into the role of
becoming the new flash and in the early
stories under Mike Barron it was all
about Wally West basically being under
the shadow of Barry can he ever truly be
as good as Barry can he ever really be
the great kind of flash superhero that
Barry Allen was causally comparing
himself to Barry Allen it wasn't until
Mike Barron left the title and Mark Waid
took over this suddenly it turned into
okay let's start focusing on the
expansion of Wally it was a natural
progression
once Wally had kind of stepped into his
role as being the flash accepted his
role as a hero then we started getting
stories like terminal velocity we
started getting stories like the return
of Barry Allen which was the basically
post-crisis origin for eobard thawne the
reverse-flash
we started getting like all these
different these different expansions on
the nature of Wally and then him growing
I guess him kind of moving on further
marrying Linda Park who I think was a
reporter at the time eventually having
giant Irish you know being involved in
Infinite Crisis Barry Allen actually
coming back you know during like the the
original flash rebirth event it's kind
of cool with all these little things but
Tom King kind of relies on this it's one
of the reasons why it's sort of a little
bit of a goodie here is because for
somebody who's new is okay cool it's is
him doing his origin for those who have
been part of the flash mythos for a long
time they can kind of look at this and
saying okay I understand where he's
coming from because like here are all
the things that Wally West has been
through over the course of his life as a
hero and that's why it's interesting
because what this does is it kind of
really allows us to sort of expand and
build on his character and like the
deficits of struggle and strife that
he's been through all this time and so
when this happens when suddenly like
after all the things that he's endured
all the laws that he's in do err to in
turn come back from the Speed Force and
find out that no one knows who he is
except for Barry and the Titans but his
wife isn't oh he is and his kids are
missing it's a crushing experience and
so as he goes through here one of the
things I want to kind of do is I want to
jump back to the very very beginning of
story because what this did is it kind
of gave us this poem that Wally was sort
of musing over and what he says is that
in the beginning when he and Linda Park
first got married she read this poem off
to him it was kind of like her vow to
him and watch what he says is that this
poem that she read was really more about
like death and rebirth it was about
sometimes we lose things but we can
always get those things back it's only
how hard it is that we basically worked
for it and it's kind of cool because
what he says is is like you know nark
adhere to that we talked about in the
last video kind of explained it to him
you know I said that it's all about
creation it's all about making things
you know it's not necessarily about
literally making things but about how
love makes things that essentially it
was really kind of a poem of hope that
that Wally West still has the chance to
speak to Linda Park he still has a
chance to get her back and by virtue of
doing that tracking down and then of
course getting his kids but at the same
time that he does this he basically
snaps his fingers creates a crack of
lightning and basically like brings back
poison ivy
he essentially resurrect her from the
dead now the cool thing about this this
is one of the important elements to
remember is that Tom Keyes not pulling
this out of his backside right like on
the surface it would be easy to assume
that when it comes to poison ivy
remember she's part of the green she's
basically part of she's she's a plant
elemental is really what she is that was
one of the things that was established
about her through Swamp Thing but you
had you had like Swamp Thing so you had
the red which is people's ability to
basically kind of commune with the
animal animal side of the world more or
less or I guess the animal side of the
universe is I can kind of expand that
beyond just the just the planet Earth
but then there's also the rot which is
basically everything dead more or less
and then there's the green which is
plant life and so walkways and I have
your physical form would die her
spiritual essence would essentially
become part of the green which means at
any point she can be brought back and
that's exactly what what while he does
he resurrects her from the dead and it's
kind of a cool thing because initially
we thought that that poison ivy was
going to be gone forever but Tom P
explicitly told us in the beginning of
hearing crisis on Twitter and various
forms of social media they're not gonna
stay dead forever there's no reason they
what that the story's designed to be
self contained is designed to be a set
of events to take place and then
effectively end with things kind of
being returned to the status quo and
that's why it's so cool is because for
everything we see here while there is
the caveat that essentially none of it
really seems to matter there's also the
benefit that at the end of it all there
could be after-effects there could be
things that kind of continue on from the
events of heroes in crisis but that's
kind of where this big revelation comes
from is because while wall-e is talking
to poison ivy what he says is I hurt you
I was supposed to help you and I didn't
I was supposed to be a hero and I didn't
at a time when you needed me I basically
let you die and the reason why was
because I wasn't really being a hero and
I apologize for that because you're
gonna have to see what comes next in
when she says what she says my death
you're going to have to watch me die and
that's the crazy thing because
essentially Wally West is in the present
watching himself die presumably coming
from the future or the past we don't
know okay
so originally I was not gonna cover this
at least not right now right like the
most anticipated comic book movie and I
would argue the most anticipated movie
of all time is coming out like tonight
why would I talk about anything but in
game that kind of baffled me right like
in games coming out it's like yeah I
know in games coming out and it's the
one thing that everybody's talking about
can you talk about spawn and it was like
no absolutely not but this but then like
I read heroes a crisis eight and I was
like oh my god like I have to cover this
because here's the thing man dude Tom
King all right those guys who don't like
Tom King you're wrong and I will tell
you why you're wrong so this whole thing
was like a giant mystery right like we
didn't know who actually killed
everybody at sanctuary and heroes in
crisis but at least not in the beginning
but then it was revealed that it was
Harley Quinn but then it was also
revealed that it was Booster Gold and
the question was well then who was it
that did it right biggest if we saw
Harley Quinn kill everyone in the
beginning and then we saw Booster Gold
kill everyone
then who actually killed everyone it was
a great big huge mystery so what this
does is it basically picks up with like
Wally West and it's the coolest thing
because what he basically says is like
this is my confession and I was just
like wow like right out of the gate like
it's dudas it's it's nuts like I'm I'm I
am dick you see this is why I like slow
builds right like a lot of people out
there don't really like slow bills they
like like I want the story told in three
issues or less which doesn't give you
enough time to really build anything up
but slow builds are awesome because the
payoff is usually worth it and like this
is one of those instances where it was
definitely worth it because when you go
through this he start like like
literally Wally starts talking about how
like he been there at sanctuary for a
few weeks you know and he was there to
recover and all that kind of cool stuff
but the funny thing about this is he
starts to talk about how he looked at
himself in relation to everybody else
and it's one of the things that we
weren't initially made aware of what
what Wally basically says here is that
with the nature of sanctuary being what
it was that all these different people
were there to basically cope with the
struggles that they didn't do it now we
knew that right like we knew the basis
behind sanctuary was that it was
supposed to be a place of healing and
maybe
method of healing was just punching you
know virtual reality drones and maybe
your method of healing was just
meditation whatever the case was all
these different heroes and even some of
the villains to a degree who were trying
to reform we're going through sanctuary
for the purpose of healing himself sort
of healing their minds healing their
their spirits and so on and so forth so
they could go forward having dealt with
all this trauma but for the most part
what we weren't really told and what
really seems to be hit on the head here
is that they were all in isolation and
it's kind of interesting because Tom
Kings would have made that ambiguous
right like all we really saw with
regards to the various characters and
heroes in crisis is like what they were
doing to heal we didn't see what they
were doing in their downtime we didn't
know if they were all like just kind of
hanging out and mingling and talking and
it's sort of socializing was kind of the
kind of the the healing method which
would have made sense because if you
were poison ivy and you were trying to
like get to a better version of yourself
then what better way to do that than to
spend time hanging out with heroes
people who normally go through and save
others but in fact all these individuals
were in a compartmentalized space that
they were basically all isolated from
one another now again that allowed for
anonymity it allowed for them to be able
to basically function without anybody
knowing what their confessions were or
what they were doing to heal which
provided a lot more privacy and it
basically allowed them to operate with
impunity in a small space without any
real consequence for what it was that
they were doing but when when Wally
started looking at this and when he
started started kind of focusing on
himself the conclusion that he came to
was that he was crazy whether the issue
here was that when he looked at
sanctuary he wasn't a place where like
all these people were going to heal in
the mind of Wally West it was all just a
front like literally everything going on
his sanctuary was designed for the
purpose of making him feel like he
wasn't that bad and so what this means
is that for the most part when he looks
at all the other people they're
basically actors that they're there just
to basically put on the show and make it
all seem legit and so he started asked
these questions why is it anonymous why
is it that that nobody really knows what
anybody else is doing and he essentially
distorted like feed into his own
ideology right and that's kind of the
cool thing here that's one of the things
that Tom King hits on might like for
whatever reason we will develop an
ideology right and then where the
thought process used to be you know in a
previous age of humanity where the
thought process used to be here is an
opinion I have let me find facts that
either you know confirm this opinion or
conflict with this opinion and if the
facts that I find conflict with my
opinion then maybe it's time for me to
reorganize my opinion in this day and
age it's I have an opinion now let me
find the facts to support it and ignore
the facts that don't and that's exactly
what happened with Wally Wally started
going through and he developed
ideology he's crazy so then he started
going through and looking at all the
information and we either twist it and
skew it or would ignore it if it didn't
support his perception and he would
basically say like this is all the
information that shows that I'm a crazy
person this is all the information this
show is that like all these things are
messed up and what he really kind of
says here is that in his mind that maybe
some of it had to do with Linda Park and
the reason why is he says like for the
most part he was isolated and alone and
that's the interesting thing about this
because when you look at Wally here
while he does do something pretty
screwed up in a lot of way she's a
victim because when you look at Wally
post DC rebirth for the most part aside
from the Titans
there was nobody really there to kind of
guide him and how to interact with with
Linda Barry did to a degree but the
problem is that Barry was he really took
kind of a cowardly wrong right it's like
hey Wally you should go and talk to
Linda and what his response was no I
don't want to and the Barry said okay
and then walked away
what Wally needed was to have his hand
forced what while he needed was to be
made to go talk to Linda Park because
Wally didn't know that's what he needed
and that's that that's something that
Barry should have been able to pick up
on because Barry was his mentor and so
following this we see one of the coolest
set of events unfold in the history of
Wally West character so so what Wally
ends up doing is he basically sits down
and he says okay I have to find out
whether or not this is a show or not I
have to find out whether or not any of
this is real but the problem with
sanctuary according to Wally is that all
the confessions that are made are
literally split into like a billion
different pieces they're drag minted all
over the place and then just kind of
scattered out into you wherever it is
that they happen to go but Wally is the
fastest man alive and so while he's like
okay well I'm just gonna grab all the
pieces and they grab all these little
digital bytes and bring them back
together again and that's what he did
Wally West was the one who recompiled
everybody's confessions he's the one
that basically brought it all back
together and then he watched all the
confessions and the issue is that when
he did that it broke him because he was
literally watching nothing but pain and
suffering for however long it took him
to watch and it basically warped and
screwed up his mind and the result was
that he hid it has simply kind of broke
him on a mental level now following this
he basically races out of the house to
catch his breath and then what he does
is he talks about the Speed Force and he
says that with the Speed Force people
look at it and they say yeah the Speed
Force is so cool he's got an accelerated
healing factor you can time travel you
can travel to other dimensions if you
vibrate the right way you can do all
kinds of really awesome things but Wally
says that like there's a huge drawback
and a huge drawback is that you're
essentially taking your portion of a
multiversal source of energy and keeping
it confined into yourself
and if it were to explode out of you
what would happen and that's what
happens here that when Wally's trying to
regain his composure when he's watching
all this pain and suffering replay in
his head when he triggers an alarm by
messing with the computer systems and
everybody comes filing out all this
energy just kind of lets loose he snaps
for a brief second and when that happens
all these people in sanctuary are killed
and so the question is what does Wally
do because he just basically killed
everyone
what is Wally do after this he
constructs a plan he basically frames
Booster Gold and Harley Quinn what he
essentially does is that because Booster
and Holly were the last two who were in
there the last two who left that what he
essentially did is he messed with their
VR systems so that when they thought
they were leaving they were actually
walking back into the VR system itself
and then he he interned modified
sanctuary so that Harley Quinn saw
Booster Gold kill everybody including
Wally West and Booster Gold saw Harley
Quinn kill everybody including Wally
West and so following that he ran five
days into the future like after they
were done he ran five days into the
future brought himself back and went and
literally had this conversation he
placed a fake body basically like he
engineered an entire crime scene and he
did this because he was with Barry Allen
for decades right for like at least 20
years of his life he knows exactly how
Barry Allen thinks and with Barry Allen
being the CSI the crime scene
investigator that the Justice League
would inevitably call in the best one in
the world he knew exactly what Barry
would look for any knew exactly what
Barry would miss he also knew what
Batman would follow up with him because
remember flash has been on T or Wally
West has been on teams with Batman
before and said well he well he's not
the best person to know exactly how
Batman thinks what he does know is how
Batman functions as a detective Wally
West tricked Barry Allen and tricked
Batman into believing that he actually
died and then what he did is he used
like he basically set up frames he
killed everyone and lied about it and so
following that like he basically said
like I had five days you know I had five
days to sit down and to create this
confession Wally West killed everyone
faked a crime scene tampered with
evidence framed Harley Quinn and Booster
Gold all for the purpose of trying to
find a way to basically escape a murder
that he made and try to find a way to do
something right to make up for what it
was that he did wrong and the only
conclusion he could come to you the only
thing that he could figure out the only
thing he believed he could do right in
order to correct what it was that he did
wrong was to confess to send this
confession directly to Lois Lane and
it's crazy because what this basically
means now is that like Wally West is a
murderer now given the circumstance in
terms of how it unfolded one of the
things that you guys will always usually
notice when it comes to superheroes and
in various color book superheroes and
Marvel superheroes in DC is they usually
get a pass right like that was one of
the best lines of secret Empire the kind
of side track here from from heroes in
crisis that was one of the best parts of
secret empire when stiva when evil
Captain America was talking to good
Captain America that literally what what
evil Captain America said was like hey
like I'm not one of your Avenger friends
right like I'm not four I'm not the
Incredible Hulk I don't get a pass it's
one of these things were like Oh end up
having to do time for what I did with
wall-e is something akin to that right
like wall-e is a hero and so the result
is that he'll be given the benefit of
the doubt if this was any other villain
out there immediately he would've been
put on trial probably sent to Arkham
worse into some other prison Bellerive
thrown into the Suicide Squad like who
knows what would have happened to them
well they certainly would not get the
benefit of the doubt right like if the
Joker had done this or if like Harley
Quinn had done this like they would have
immediately been thrown in there but
with Wally it's like well but I mean
he's a good guy though so like we got to
give him the benefit of the doubt I mean
sure he did a really bad thing but like
we like him though so like it's okay
like that's that's literally what it'll
turn into and it's so intriguing because
it basically kind of throws into the
idea of like what happens to Wally next
where do we go from here Wally is a
confessed killer
he confessed to his crime what follows
after this one of the best comics I've
read in a long time I love heroes in
crisis it's absolutely amazing okay so
you guys have been asking for it so we
are finally covering the the conclusion
to heroes in crisis also FYI Tuesday
Thursday and Saturday we're covering
Dark Phoenix saga so that we can have
that out further for the weekend and
then we jump back into your regularly
scheduled programming which is basically
almost everything coming out from Marvel
because we have a lot of catching up to
do but um with heroes in crisis number
nine this basically answers the question
that everybody's been asking why did
Wally do what he did how did it all
unfold what's going on right because
well heroes in crisis like we have had
questions answered but it's been kind of
cloak and dagger encounter murkiness
kind of they're like half answers and so
it's just sort of like all right like we
needed a definitive explanation to all
of this stuff and so what this does is
it initially picks up with the arrival
of that girl of Booster Gold of Blue
Beetle in Harley Quinn now remember
these four have been just essentially
like figuring everything out at least
trying to figure everything out and
under normal circumstances we would
assume Batman would be the one to arrive
to the conclusion about everything but
remember Harley Quinn and Booster Gold
were the ones who were on the scene and
so the result is they actually kind of
have an
site into what's going on that nobody
else in the Justice League has at the
same time they were believed to have
been the killers and so they were
essentially underground and so what you
had was bat woman and Blue Beetle who
basically ran upon it now of course bat
woman running up on Harley Quinn was
kind of hearing the two together even
though they've never really been like
directed enemies probably Quinn's more
of like a Batman enemy but also kind of
an enemy of the bat family I felt like
in terms of who she comes into conflict
most it's Batman that's kind of what we
expect from her character really
alongside the Joker or even by herself
which she or when she's on a team with
Gotham City sirens but the fact remains
that with Booster Gold of Blue Beetle
again this makes sense right for the
people who have been reading DC for a
while Booster Gold and Blue Beetle go
way back like they're you know in
exceedingly good friends and so when
Booster Gold shows up on the doorstep of
Ted Kord as his hey man I didn't do this
you have to believe me
Ted Kord response is okay then let's
figure out who did and that's kind of
why we have all these guys here and so
when Harley shows up they're immediately
met by the arrival of like poison ivy
and this is kind of a cool thing it's
actually a cool little moment here
because when it comes to to Harley Quinn
what we do see the human side of her and
this sister like she feels emotion she
cries she loves things like that it's
usually accompanied by like insanity or
some crazy set of circumstances we very
rarely ever get to see Halle Quinn just
be a tried and true person right and
it's one of the things that we tend to
forget that like at the end of the day
despite her her you know various
escapades with the Joker and evil with
poison ivy despite her dealings with the
Suicide Squad and so on Harley Quinn is
still for the most part a rational
person she's crazy but she's not like
Joker crazy right she don't like off the
deep end never to return to sanity and
the funny thing about this is that
poison ivy is kind of her anchor to her
sanity right it's like the one person
that keeps her from like falling over
the edge but to have been romantically
involved they were a couple of it to the
point when like poison ivy basically
died now this is also a very big
revelation here that's really kind of
built on for the last issue over the
last couple issues and as kept going by
Tom King and is basically the idea that
poison ivy is essentially immortal right
like she has like what she does is
something akin to like Baltimore and the
Horcrux was right like so long as those
war cookies exist Baltimore would always
come back the idea behind this is that
with poison ivy a part of herself was
put into a flower and in that plant that
that flower was planted of course by
Wally West five days after she died and
what that means is that so long as she
puts in essence of herself into some
part of the green then she can always
basically reman efest she can return now
of course for those of you guys who were
coming into this brand
the green is is just kind of a
colloquial name for like nature more or
less insofar as like plant life right
you have the red which is animals and
then you have the rot which is the death
of all things more or less you know like
death itself to a degree like rotting
decaying that kind of a thing but just
behind this is that with poison ivy
being part of the green it means that
she's literally part of nature right
like she's on par with Swamp Thing and
so basically by establishing this again
Tom King says like so long as a part of
her essence is tapped into the green
meaning like it's in a flower or a plant
or something like that and is
reconnected to the green reconnected to
like nature itself to the plant aspect
of this world or any other then what it
means is that she can basically
reconstitute her physical form and then
of course it seems as though she has all
of her memories intact she recalls her
leak when she knows the two of them were
together it's a pretty cool is a pretty
cool little thing and it really kind of
like adds on to the existing nature of
poison ivy right we always kind of knew
to a degree there was an aspect of
immortality that we just didn't really
know how far it went of course this is
when it switches over to Wally West and
this is kind of a cool theme because you
sort of have like that woman you have
Harley you have poison ivy Booster Gold
and Ted Kord we're just sort of watching
these two Wally West's you know
encounter one another and it's because
Wally West feels totally alone and this
is when the huge explanation comes this
is what it's all basically revealed that
what we find out here is that when Wally
had pieced together all these little
bits of information right like these
little tidbits of confessions and so on
when he experienced like this huge
influx of like pain and suffering from
all these heroes he cracked and of
course we know that led to him just kind
of letting off the Speed Force power and
killing everybody in the vicinity that
part had already been explained what
comes next is this idea that in Wally's
mind because he had killed all these
people what he needed to do was
something that would basically right the
wrong he needed an equally good thing to
match the equally bad thing and so what
he ended up doing was running five days
into the future grabbing himself and
then killing himself bringing it back
and then dropping it off and of course
as we know that would spare him five
days but the logic behind his actions is
what we didn't entirely know his initial
indication was wal just run back in time
and stop myself from blowing up but as
he points out with Barry Allen and the
flashpoint event we don't know what
ramification that would cause right I
mean for Barry it was keeping his mom
alive right like it was saving the life
of his mom and that changed the entire
universe something that's small that
seemed smoke for the most part to be
confined strictly to Barry right like it
wasn't like he saved Krypton from
blowing up and he saved Batman's parents
you know and he prevented
from being thrown into like the the VAT
of chemicals at an ace chemical plant
and he stopped to fasion being splashed
with acid its lucky he did all those
things right it's just he saved his
mom's life and that fundamentally
altered the entirety of the universe now
Doomsday Clock is kind of hitting on
that in sync well it really may have
been more Manhattan didn't like Barry
Allen but at the end of the day the
actions of Barry fundamentally changed
the way the universe was organized and
structured and what wally was doing as
he was looking at that and saying ok all
Barry did was save his mom's life now
we're talking about me going back in
time and preventing the deaths of a
whole bunch of heroes we have no idea
what impact that would have on the
universe so he said ok that's done then
the question became ok then what good
can I do in order to fix this and that's
why he basically compiled all that
information all the confessions release
it to Lois Lane and then had her dump it
to the press it forced the hand of
Superman is because what it did is a for
Superman to come out is like the world's
premier hero right like the one hero
everybody looks up to you and the one
hero that pretty much everyone trusts
came out and said guys what you seen is
real it's not a dupe it's not a trick
it's not some CGI Adobe After Effects
it's us as heroes confessing our darkest
moments the things that we regret the
most of mistakes we've made and
basically saying like we're humans we
screw up we feel pain and all that kind
of stuff we don't show you because you
have to look up to us and what are we if
we're emotional if we feel pain and we
feel suffering and we want to give up
sometimes and we do bad things if we're
not the people you've built us up to be
then we're nothing we're nothing
different than you and if you can't rely
on us to save the world then you have to
rely on yourselves to save the world
which can lead to absolute anarchy
because then suddenly everybody becomes
a vigilante you need us to be heroes and
you need to see us as heroes therefore
we could not let you see us as anything
but that that's why we had sanctuary
that's why we kept everything hidden
from but Superman going out stepping out
and revealing all that basically meant
that like the world sees heroes as
people as it was kind of a fun thing
kind of an interesting thing because
what this does is it it's halves into
wall-e and it really kind of changes the
entire dynamic of like heroes in crisis
because now it's no longer heroes in
crisis now it's the crisis of Wally West
right like I was I was a Denver Comic
Con this past weekend and I was talking
to Sal and Hugh and I were running over
like what we thought about heroes in
crisis and he made that good point he's
like it's the crisis of Wally West
because when you look at Wally as a
character that's why is it so cool when
you look at Wally as a character all
he's known since the events of rebirth
is loss right like that that's all he's
known before the events of Flashpoint
before the events
rebirth bet that Wally West had Jai and
iers he had his kids he had Linda he had
his family he had everything that he
ever wanted right I mean in a lot of
ways he lived the perfect life that was
the cool thing about Wally and that's
why so many fans loved him so much right
like crisis on Infinite Earths happens
Barry Allen basically dies or at least
was supposed to have died ends up
joining the Speed Force and he's gone
for the next 20 years this sets the
stage for Wally to basically become the
new flash and he spends the first little
bit of it under the shadow of Barry and
then finally steps out of that shadow
and says I can be my own hero then he
starts doing things like tapping into
the Speed Force he starts doing things
like mainlining the Speed Force he
starts becoming the fastest of all the
speedsters he starts developing a new
set of powers that not even Barry had
and then it comes up where he basically
marries the reporter Linda Park did he
has joy then he has iris there was a
point in time right before the events of
Flashpoint when Wally had it all he had
everything he ever needed he had friends
he had family the whole nine yards and
then flashpoint happens and it's all
gone in the blink of an eye everything
he knows is is gone he encounters dr.
Manhattan we know that from the events
of Doomsday Clock he tries to stop dr.
Manhattan Manhattan pushes him back into
the Speed Force and while he's stuck
back there again eventually he makes his
way out when Barry finally realizes who
he is only to come back to the real
world and realize the only people who
seem to recall him are Wally maybe a
couple of the heroes and like the Titans
and that's it but the people who mean
the most to him his children he doesn't
know where they are his wife doesn't
know who he is he's lost everything
and so in this moment when he basically
goes to like confess the things he's
struggling with when he can find a brief
moment of reprieve he kills everyone
with a Speed Force powers it's like
Wally can't do anything but screw up
right like ever since the official
events of Flashpoint he's just out of
sync with the way things are supposed to
be that he can't do anything right and
that's the struggle of Wally West is he
went from being the hero to a guy who
can't do anything right and that's
what's so crushing is because ultimately
he feels totally alone and so in this
moment they're kind of stuck in a
recursive time loop right because the
question is if this all kind of repeats
the same way right like Wally runs into
the pad to run through the future five
days he grabs that future version of
himself he brings it back you know kills
him drops the body off and then
everybody thinks that while he's dead
and that buys in the five days in order
to bring together all the confessions
and then give it to Lois Lane who
doubled to the press and Superman has to
talk if it always plays out that way
then how do you break that loop now this
is where Tom King kind of just I
wouldn't say screws the pooch but
certainly takes the story into the wreck
where it seems to kind of take away from
the impact of everything because then
what you end up having is booster to all
new charms up and says hey just run to
the future and just get a cone of
yourself and like kill the clone bring
it back drop the body off and then
you're fine you don't have to kill
yourself five days in the future and so
like that's it it's such an easy way out
to be honest it's such an easy way out
but that's kind of the funny thing is
because if you look at heroes in crisis
as a traditional superhero story then
yes that ending sucks and it ruins the
whole thing but if you look at it for
what it's supposed to be which is a
deconstruction of Wally West it's not
about the steps that while he takes in
order to win the day it's about what's
going on with Wally how does he view the
world if you look at it through those
eyes the entire nature of the story
changes and I think this is where a lot
of people struggled I think a lot of
people kind of went into this because DC
built it that way so you really can't
fault them for it but a lot of people
went into this like it's a great big
huge event and it's a it's a huge story
and like all kinds of crazy things are
gonna happen DC didn't really build it
as a deconstruction of Wally DC built it
built it as like this is the next big
event you know and it's like okay and
then you get into and you realize this
doesn't quite work the way it's supposed
to now the thing about this this is kind
of the cool moment the thing about this
is that Wally kind of sits down and says
okay so I've done this right like I went
to the future I grabbed a clone I
dropped it off I killed him and that's
the body they discover done and done the
recursive time loop disclosed things can
move forward there's still the question
of what happens to Wally what what goes
on now because Wally kill people and
then he lied about it he framed Booster
Gold and Harley Quinn and then he forced
Superman's handed of a bunch of
information that really probably
shouldn't have been dumped in the first
place you know so what we're talking
about here is a guy who engaged in
murder and espionage so like what do you
do with a guy like that well of course
Wally ends up being taken to prison and
just kind of dropped off in a Cell now
it's sort of left open-ended by it by
Tom King and the sense of like Wally's
there but we don't really know what
comes next
I imagine that question will be answered
in Joshua Williamson's flash right like
Joshua waves will probably pick up from
that and and go from there either that
or Williamson will ignore it
innocent hire T and it'll be like heroes
and crisis never happened and that'll
just be the end of it I don't know how
you treat the story like it never
happened
if it was confined strictly to Wally and
he basically managed to open the time
loop and closed it and no one knew about
it then sure you could just kind of
sweep this under the rug and say here's
a crisis never happened you're talking
about and call it a day but like the
confessions of the super heroes being
blasted out to the world you can't
really sweep that under the rug there's
no real is no real like coming back from
that but at the end of the day again
heroes in crisis you know like I said if
you look at
for what it is right the way it was
designed to be viewed then it's a
beautifully done story but the issue is
that a lot of folks are kind of let in
under the belief that it was a big
crisis crossover kind of grand pooh-bah
event and and that was it so I don't
know I mean I'm I'm curious what do you
guys think I'm curious what your
opinions are because I'm sure they're
gonna very I'm sure they're gonna be
people who are gonna be like heroes a
crisis sucked and they're gonna be
people who are like heroes in crisis was
amazing so I'm curious what your all's
response is what you're all sought is I
enjoyed it but again I think the ending
kind of took away from what could have
been a great story even with it being a
deconstruction of wall-e but who the
less let me know what you guys think if
you are new here too comments explained
to make sure you guys at the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video then make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]